welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition and this episode
were discussing one of the worst pieces
of Rage Bay I've ever seen normally
wouldn't cover this sort of thing but it
seems to be picking up a lot of traction
and honestly I'm just fed up with seeing
these same sort of articles over and
over the piece comes from the Mary Sue
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down why it's disingenuous
unfounded rage bait that has no real
standing or evidence to support its wild
claims without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking the
video now let's get into the breakdown
okay so as mentioned earlier the report
comes from news website the Mary Sue and
it makes some pretty outlandish claims
that though they sound like they have
basis in reality I actually completely
fabricated the headline that they're
going with is misogynists already
bashing birds of prey without seeing it
where have I seen this before and from
there it pretty much devolves into a
tirade of hyperbolic language to enrage
readers into thinking there's an agenda
led by men that don't like women in
films I'll go through the report bit by
bit in a moment and break down why it's
BS but to summarize it the article
states that there's a male movement on
the internet that completely hate all
female at films and don't want them to
exist now obviously with such a huge
unsought of backlash against women you
think they would have a plethora of
tweets posts comments and more to choose
from surely this applies unlimited
surely they would have at least one
example of this to add to the discord
one just just one nope nope nope
throughout the entire article
there is absolutely no tweet included no
posts no one named so yeah it's pretty
much unfounded
unlike the author I actually did some
due diligence and I've spent an hour
searching for anti female birds of prey
posts and through all of that searching
all of that unearthing all of that
investigative reporting I think it's
called I found one
one in total that is from Matthew Kadesh
who said you know why birds of prey is
going to bomb just like Charlie's Angels
did they've removed any sex appeal these
characters had to appeal to a female
girl-power audience instead of the core
male comic-book audience they literally
don't know who they're making this movie
for now right Lee the guy got a lot of
backlash from men and the only reason it
actually picked up any attention is
because a lot of accounts quoted it and
called the guy in idiot you could scroll
through the replies forever and I'd say
pretty much everyone called him dumb
stupid and ignorant but apparently this
one tweet from one man is all men and
men hate women now because the guy said
the movie would bomb anyway that's the
only two I could find of this apparent
movement of misogyny that is sweeping
the globe right now and killing
everything that might even have a hint
of pink in it even though there's a
thousand times more tweeters for men
calling the guy a [ __ ] but anyway
ignore that that's not gonna get clicks
to the article is it now let's break
down the article itself outrage has
taken over the Internet
women taking a genre typically dominated
by men ruining the childhoods of those
fans who love the male dominated films
how dare we female to take the throne
for ourselves I don't know why this
question marks at the end of all that
it's not really a question but ignore
that first off again I haven't seen
anyone saying that they've had their
childhood ruined because birds of prey
is coming out but yet do go on now what
yeah am i writing this from is it from
the 2016 Ghostbusters movie that was
torn to shreds before I even came out
what am I talking about 2017 s Wonder
Woman maybe it's 2019 s Captain Marvel
or maybe I'm looking to the future of
Black Widow or what's happening right
now this second with birds of prey
secondly let's just break down this
entire statement and why it's wrong
Ghostbusters was torn to shreds because
it was bad there wasn't an anti
Ghostbusters movement on the Internet
and similar to this article there wasn't
actually many people slamming it
there's probably just one guy that got
the blame for it all probably that
bloody Matthew Kaddish the spokesman for
all men as we all know you also know how
we know that Ghostbusters wasn't any
good because the studio completely wiped
it from the canon after one film and are
now making a sequel to the original two
movies so yeah clearly it wasn't good
right let's end that secondly the Wonder
Woman comment I don't know what
alternative universe you come from in
the DC multiverse but wonder woman was
not hated the film did phenomenal and
there was no anti FEMA movement in the
lead-up to it even before the film's
release people were saying the character
was the best bit of Batman V Superman so
yeah you're wrong shut up as for Captain
Marvel most of if pretty much all of the
backlash from that came from brie Larson
saying that she didn't want her films
reviewed by white men she said that the
air naturally white men were annoyed by
it and they even claimed that the film
should have just did what Wonder Woman
did which backs up the prior point in
that people didn't hate Wonder Woman
can't wait for all this backlash and
Wonder Woman 1984 I can just hear
Matthew Kennish tape and now he's so
angry anyway apparently the author can
also see into the future and knows
already that Black Widow won't do well
which at least at least they're
admitting they have no evidence for that
as it hasn't happened yet the article
goes on to say time and time again it's
hard to even have an honest critical
conversation about these female at
movies because of men and some women on
the internet trashing the movie in bad
faith before we even get a chance to see
it so let's take a moment
buckle in and explore why men and again
some women on the Internet continue to
be the worst ass so it's women as well
maybe it's not misogyny and if it's a
women never mind
time and time again we are confronted
with the knowledge that in order for
women to succeed in any given format we
have to fight an uphill battle to get
there let's look at it for the sake of
argument and because it was the most
recent movie to go through this Captain
Marvel well not that recent I mean it
was last year prior to the release it
was dragged continually by men and some
women who didn't
even see the movie yet they just hate
the idea of Marvel which had previously
been dominated by men having their first
female lead maybe it was because it
wasn't natasha romanoff which is a whole
other subject but it's probably more
just the idea of a woman getting
literally anything I'm waiting for the
Black Widow attacks next it's exhausting
which is the easiest way of putting it
we live in a world where any male nerd
movie that stars a woman is going to get
attacked before it's even on its feet
birds of prey is getting it in multiple
ways
again it's not even saying that the
female lead like sex appeal because why
the men watch the trailer and didn't
like that Harley Quinn said f off to the
Joker I searched far and wide for one
tweet on how people were annoyed by the
f off - the Joker comment and it may
surprise you to learn that there weren't
any
I'm sure the author knows this though
which is why it's not being included in
the article also it's funny that they
mentioned Joker because in the run-up to
that film a lot of media outlets claimed
that it was violent towards women and
that the movie which was about an in
Cell male would also trigger more
violence I've included evidence of this
on screen now however unlike the birds
of prey movement it wasn't labeled as a
feminist uprising or anything like that
and the aims of the reports weren't
there to cause division between men and
women sadly as we all know though Joker
did go on to cause a lot of violence and
so far there have been a total of zero
deaths
rest in peace all those people who died
because of Joker the article then goes
on to say when it comes down to it I
guess I want to know when will this end
how many successful movies need to come
out with women as the leads before we
finally just have an acceptance of these
movies do women need to start our own
franchise and just run with it from
there in the hopes that men of the
Internet don't find us well I think you
just answered your own question there
the fact that you're saying that there
are already a lot of successful movies
shows that it has ended surely like how
many successful movies need to come out
you've just said that when will this end
also it has ended because there's only
one tweet on the entire internet and I'm
pretty sure if you
just block that guy and I'll end for you
yay I saved a life I'd like for one
female led movie to come out without
having to listen to the angry man
screaming about how it's bad before
they've even laid eyes on it
yeah Wonder Woman and yes I know that
Wonder Woman 1984 and the unnamed
Captain Marvel sequel will do well
because the first installments did but
that's because both Wonder Woman and
Captain Marvel had to be rallied behind
by women everywhere because of said
backlash I mean did they though
did they really because I'm pretty sure
you don't get the box office that they
did from men being rallied into the
cinema by women as if that was the case
that all women would have done the same
amount as those movies wouldn't it yeah
Wonder Woman and Captain Marvel was
successful because they were part of
established comic-book franchises that
predominantly involved men and a male
audience this audience then continued to
see Wonder Woman and Captain Marvel
hence their success for yeah there's a
big anti female movement I would have
loved to quickly look at both Wonder
Woman and Captain Marvel without feeling
like any criticism would open the door
for men on the Internet to tank it and
ruin whatever hopes I had for sequels
granted there wasn't much about either
of those movies I would change but
that's not particularly the point so
what is your point I want to have that
weight lifted off me so I can go into a
movie and just enjoy it without having
to feel like I have to scream about four
months to counteract the jerks on the
internet who hate anything that isn't
filled with white men named Chris birds
of prey does have a white man named
Chris though so basically how many
successful female led nerd base movies
have to happen before we can stop this
frankly effing stupid trend of bashing a
movie non-stop just because it isn't
filled with male heroes when will this
madness end hopefully the day you stop
making things up about this movement in
your head I feel like a lot of your
problems are caused by you thinking
they're some anti female movement
there's not there's one tweet Matthew
Kaddish what have you done so yeah
that's the entire article as we said
it's completely fabricated and unfounded
this is purely an opinion piece that is
making outlandish statements
as facts and then giving absolutely no
evidence beyond I think therefore it is
rightly so the article has been torn to
shreds and a couple of the more notable
points I've seen are fifty percent of
the population is female if it's only
the angry white man's fault why are
these movies flopping so hard this meme
that kind of breaks down Elizabeth Banks
his comments shows how female at films
often do well when they're well made
I'll bring this tweet up as I think it
sums it up perfectly it feels like we
are being shamed into seeing a movie and
if we decide to maybe give it a Miss
then we're a misogynist
it's a ridiculous statement especially
in light of the prior female that movies
have done well still though I really I
shouldn't slam this website too hard I
mean they are just wanting to push
female films wait why isn't this the
same website that slammed earlier battle
angel because men liked it wait wait
they did wait so they want men to
support these female led films however
when they do it's a bad thing
yeah I have no idea how this website is
verified on Twitter because just seems
to be full of unfounded nonsense that is
made purely to drive clicks to their
website when they know for a fact
they're making it up I'm no founding for
it and it's bad bad people websites like
this are put in place purely to cause
hate and division and therefore they're
not really aiming to have the Equality
utopia that they claim to want they
thrive on negativity and personally I'm
just sick of it when will it end when
well we need to stop paying attention to
these sites and their BS stories and I'm
angry at myself for even covering it now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the report so comment below and let
me know if you agree with me or not and
if you do then please share this video
so hopefully we can start putting an end
to these kinds of articles you enjoy
this and want to see a more fun-filled
breakdown then check out our video on
what to expect from the upcoming Disney
CinemaCon panel in March we go over all
of the rumors announcements and more so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to learn a bit more about the
Marvel slate if you want to support the
channel from this little it's 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way to making videos like this you
get access to content early and can
suggest video topics and breakdowns and
if you want to come chat to us after the
show either follow us a definition
whitey
or click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people who are
subscribed to the channel and this month
II can win dr. sleep and all you have to
do is comment on a video and make sure
you sub with notifications on the more
videos you comment on the more you have
a chance of winning the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of February
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like it subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this I've been definition you've been
the best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]